ce soir amarat oualit bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
tout d'abord comment allez vous a quelle
est la nature de votre votre rôle
j'allais dire dans ces manifestations
vous vous présentez comme journaliste
airy scop et twitter alors je fais des
reportages indépendant sur périscope ça
veut dire de base j'ai commencé il ya
deux ans et tj les jeunes à faire des
lives périscope
on peut quand dépens d'angers plus que
puisque 500 diffusion est donc là il ya
presque dire si moi je commence à faire
des images plus nettes parce que le live
c'est un peu compliqué second il ya la
4g ça marche pas très bien et donc je
faisais des images et je vends aux
médias je peux faire des plis j'ai fait
quelques piges pour les médias j'ai déjà
proposé avec plusieurs médias et donc je
me présente indépendant parce que je
fais toujours des gymnases libre je fais
ce que je veux dans la manifestation
c'est à dire je suis sur place je filme
ce qui se passe les tensions en temps
réel et donc en général je me présente
en tant que journaliste et reporter
d'image indépendant alors que nous
est-il arrivé hier précisément amar
alors ce qui s'est passé hier c'est que
je couvrais comme d'habitude d'une
manifestation contre la loi de la
sécurité globale on pige pour un média
étranger et donc ce qui s'est passé je
couche commencé très tôt donc je suis
arrivé à 14 heures et je commence à
filmer la manifestation à gambetta ça
commençait à porte des lilas c'était
très calme
ça commence à être un peu tendu et donc
bon il ya eu usage de lacrymogènes par
les forces de l'ordre pour disperser la
foule parce que c'était très très tendu
au début et donc après le soir à la fin
de la manifestation on arrive au tout ça
sur la place de la république et des
jeux de grenade
la jl belle parce que je me suis trompé
sur twitter j'ai mis 10 ans sert clément
mais en fait c'était la gn de l par des
confrères il ment et ment corriger et
donc et des éclats de grenade un peu
partout sur la place de la république
pour disperser les manifestants donc
j'étais au coeur de la de temps
seulement la force de la brave m mes
charges et la manif manifestants pour
qu'ils dispersent à la fin de la manif
et donc moi j'étais au collet sur les
policiers poursuit le même c'est un peu
ce qui se passe sur le front est
deux minutes après j'ai fini j'ai donc
que la manifestation s'est arrêtée un
peu ça s'est calmé un peu et usage de
lacrymogènes
je range ma caméra je suis parti à côté
pour voir un peu ce que j'ai vu ce que
j'ai fait de l'école vidéo et hop je
reçois une grenade de jm2l entre mes
jambes et ça m'a fait vraiment mal ça
m'a fait un trou on a vu là est vraiment
très très mal exactement on à la photo
sur twitter donc je les poster direct
gelé post évident c'est ce trait c'est
donc après ce qui s'est passé donc ça a
tourné sur twitter sur facebook
j'étais obligé de dénoncer ça parce que
ça me faisait mal je faisais que mon
travail de journaliste
et donc après j'étais avec les pompiers
de deux pas de paris dans la
manifestation ils m'ont pris en charge
et qu'on est parti à l'hôpital
saint-antoine aux urgences et voilà
après pour l'instant je suis encore un
peu macho j'ai encore la bulle sûr mais
ça instant je me repose je suis en arrêt
de travail et donc voilà c'est la
première fois que vous êtes blessé
puisque vous avez filmé beaucoup de
manifestations a priori alors il ya
longtemps qu'on va dire il ya six mois
je n'ai pris un coup de flash ball dans
le mollet à droite et la grenade c'est
la première fois que je prends cher
comme ça sur une blessure grave pour moi
le flash-ball n'était pas non plus très
grave parce que j'étais loin de deux
policiers comme une matière et dessus je
sais pas pourquoi mais sur la glace
était vraiment violent et
j'avais pas mal aux oreilles mais ça m'a
fait vraiment mal côté tibétain sur le
tibet a donc jamais vraiment très très
mal et de base quand j'étais dans la
manifestation avec des strip me dit
comment is it et là ils m'ont dit on va
appeler les pompiers mois de vache c'est
dans l'adrénaline je voulais encore
quand tu n'as film maudit c'est très
dangereux
je voyais pas bien en fait l'image et
c'est après que je me rends compte grâce
au strip me dit qu'en fait que c'est
grâce à eux que je suis parti à
l'hôpital parce que sinon moi je pensais
à partir rentrer chez moi ça va partir
tout seul donc c'était comment comment
est-ce que vous travaillez est ce que
vous vous essayez de vous identifié
comme étant justement journaliste
indépendant comment est ce que vous
prenez vos précautions pour vous
identifier
face aux forces de l'ordre alors il est
une agence qui est indépendante c'est un
ami à moi qui a créé une agence de
presse que je peux pas la citer il m'a
filé une carte de presse il m'a offert
une carte presse et que je travaille pas
pour lui non mais finissent à protéger
dans les manifestations au ton qu'aux
journalistes parce que vous êtes habillé
en noir que ça donc on peut peut-être
vous êtes habillé en noir quand mon fils
n'ont pas forcément on peut pas vous
confondre avec non non non non je suis
pas bien en or alain pas du tout pas du
tout ah non non je suis pas bien au noir
je suis habillé en jeans gémeaux casque
de protection mais à faire ma carte
même ma caméra avec les reporters j'ai
des confrères avec moi qui sont là sur
place et je suis pas bien au noir mais
pas du tout c'est pas le c'est pas le
but et on en même temps aussi je filme
pas je suis pas collé toujours son vers
les manifestants
je suis sur les deux côtés côté
policiers quand ils chargent concocté
manifestants j'essaie de faire des
images neutre et je suis pas non plus à
bien au noir et je suis pas non plus
visés tout on sent derrière vraiment
j'ai pris les grenats c'est la première
fois que je prends ce à quoi j'ai pas
compris pourquoi comment vous analysez
justement alors les circonstances est ce
que c'est un accident puisque on a vu qu
effectivement qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
tirs de ces grenades et de grenades de
désencerclement à la dispersion hier
soir donc comment est-ce que vous
analysez votre blessure est ce que c'est
les risques du métier
moi je pense que c'est le risque du
métier mais c'était un peu abusé puisque
en fait il ya un moment ils ont chargé
les forces de l'ordre ont chargé pour
disperser un peu les manifestants la
tension ça s'est calmé un peu et encore
il ya eu des grenades et je n'ai reçu
une
il y avait encore une troisième à côté
de membres c'est un peu loin puisque je
suis parti aux coraux quand j'étais
blessé je suis éloigné de tout je me
suis mis dans un coin il y avait les
strips ludique qui sont occupés de moi
je sais c'est un peu abusé mais c'est le
risque des métiers bien sûr c'est le
risque des mythes et c'est à dire demain
moi je que je fais j'aime bien et je
peux pas non plus même je me reposais
bien sûr pour la blessure je pas sortir
maintenant parce que c'est dangereux
mais dans une semaine si je tout se
passe bien pour la cicatrice est tout
tout avance je reprends mon travail de
reporter est ce que vous constatez une
réelle augmentation de la détention et
des violences au cours de ces
manifestations le maintien de l'ordre
qui est aussi assez critique et même en
dehors de france
oui alors depuis les gilet jaune c'était
déjà très très tendue et là j'ai
l'impression qu'on reprend en fait un
troisième année de tensions parce qu'il
ya eu aussi la récente de la retraite et
là c'est la tension allemande de plus en
plus j'étais étonné parce que quand bêta
streit ont vu j'étais le vers 18 heures
je tiens encore à gambetta je pensais
pas qu'à la place de la république
c'était tendu donc je reçois un message
pas répondrai avec 10 as marre il faut y
aller la place de la république c'est
très très tendue et j'arrive j'ai dit
mais j'étais vraiment étonné par cette
colère la de deux côtés c'est à dire les
forces de l'ordre s'il était présent il
est chargé c'était c'était un peu
violent de deux côtés il y avait pas il
n'y avait pas ce côté langage entre les
manifestants et forces armées avait pas
de négociation c'était vraiment de
l'action entre les forces de l'ordre et
les manifestants c'est très très tendue
c'est à dire même les manifestants
pacifiques les syndicats qu'ils étaient
présents et ils sont ils n'avaient pas
tant de manifester ils sont partis
directement pris leur camion ils sont
rentrés de lacrymogènes partout de la
fumée et du feu partout dans le monde
merci beaucoup en tout cas marc touati
de votre témoignage ce soir en direct
sur arte france